we're told that a board game has players
roll two
three-sided dice these exist and
actually i looked it up they do exist
and they're actually fascinating
and subtract the numbers showing on the
faces
the game only looks at non-negative
differences for example if a player
rolls a 1
and a 3 the difference is 2.
let d represent the difference in a
given role
construct the theoretical probability
distribution of
d so pause this video and see if you can
have a go at that before we work through
it together
all right now let's work through it
together
so let's just think about all of the
scenarios for the two die
so let me draw a little table here so
let me do it like that
and let me do it like this and then let
me put a little
divider right over here and
for this top this is going to be die 1
and then this is going to be die two die
one
can take on one two or
three and die two could be one
two or three and so let me
finish making this a bit of a table here
and what we want to do is look at the
difference but the non-negative
difference so we'll always subtract
the lower die from the higher die so
what's the difference here
well this is going to be zero if i roll
a 1 and a 1.
now what if i roll a 2 and a 1 well here
the difference is going to be
2 minus 1 which is 1. here the
difference is 3 minus 1
which is 2. now what about right over
here
well here the higher die is two the
lower one is
one right over here so two minus one
is one two minus two is
zero and now this is going to be the
higher roll
die one is going to have the higher role
in this scenario three minus two is one
and then right over here three minus one
is
two now if die one rolls a two
die two rolls a three die three is
higher
three minus two is one and then three
minus three
is 0. so we've come up with all of the
scenarios
and we can see that we're either going
to end up with a 0 or
1 or a 2 when we look at the positive
difference
so there's a scenario of getting a 0
a 1 or a 2. those are the different the
different
differences that we could actually get
and so let's think about the probability
of each of them
what's the probability that the
difference is 0
well we can see that 1 2
of the nine equally likely outcomes
results in a difference of zero so it's
going to be three out of nine
or one-third what about
a difference of let me use blue
one well we could see there are one
two three four of the nine scenarios
have that
so there is a four ninth probability and
then
last but not least a difference of two
well there's two
out of the nine scenarios that have that
so there is a
two ninths probability right over there
and we're done and we're done we've
constructed the theoretical probability
distribution of d